our next speaker well first i met this
speaker through twitter by the way um
she often posted a bunch of stuff about
stan and i said oh cool i know stan i
answer questions i looked at her
research previous talks and it looks
like she has some really cool stuff to
say so i asked do you want to speak at
the conference and that's how this works
folks if i catch you on twitter if you
say hi to me sometimes like hey do you
want to give a talk that's literally
what happens so come say hi to me at
some point we're not in person you're
seeing a person say hi not tweet me
right but she's also an ems an emt
volunteer and has responded to over 600
911 calls
please welcome alexa
hi everyone and thanks jared for the
great introduction
i'm gonna assume you can all see the
slides and everything's working smoothly
unless someone interrupts me in a panic
otherwise
today we're talking about r for the
planet
i thought when i gave this talk we'd all
be in the same room but we're still all
on the same planet
you can see it underneath your feet if
you look down wherever you are
i am
a ecologist and an environmental data
scientist
and today i'm going to talk to you a
little bit about my work and also about
how you as data scientists might be able
to interface with it a little bit
as someone who works on the environment
i thought i'd get some frequently asked
questions out of the way because this is
often where my conversations start
humans and our activities are reshaping
the planet
we know that that's true and it's
happening in lots of ways but the most
high profile controversial is often how
we are
uh reshaping the climate through our
emissions of greenhouse gases we know
that that's happening and we know that
most of the effects have not been great
and we also know that it's us
but crucially
we also know that it's not too late a
lot of climate scientists are fond of
saying that no matter how fast you're
going on a highway you can always put
your foot on the brake
and i'll add as an ecologist that
our impacts on the planet go beyond just
changing the climate we're also changing
water soils we're cutting down forests
we're changing the chemistry of the
oceans and these are all issues that
i've worked on and i'm happy to talk to
you about if they matter to you
so this talk has a lot of links in it
and you'll the url is is up here you can
go find the talk on github and follow
the links i know this is just a
presentation where you can't do that
but i've included a lot related to
climate and climate change if there's
anything that you always wanted to know
and never gotten answered
and because i know we're all on twitter
i've also linked to a number of great
climate scientists and environmental
journalists who might be interesting for
you to engage with
like i said i'm an ecologist and an
environmental data scientist i use large
scale data sets on biodiversity uh large
scale meaning over large spatial extents
and also often going far back into the
past to understand patterns and
processes in nature as a scientist this
is just a really cool thing to study
but i'm also doing this with the hope of
informing and improving the way that we
manage natural resources and conserve
biodiversity
and i do all of this work in our despite
the fact that i study nature mostly the
oceans which we'll get to i never
actually leave my office and i just code
all day like many of you
so i thought i'd introduce you to the
environmental data science community and
explain to you why we all use our which
by and large we do
first of all as you i'm sure no r is
really good at statistics
many people who are academic scientists
using r came from languages like matlab
or programs like arcgis
and are used to having really good
access to statistical tools that are
really easy to use and are i use a lot
of bayesian statistics which we'll talk
about more in a second
r also facilitates transparency and
reproducibility and i i can't overstate
how big of a deal this is for my field
first of all
it's an open source language unlike
things like matlab that some of my
colleagues use so
simply by definition it's much more
transparent and reproducible because
everyone can access and ideally rerun
your code
you probably remember learning the
scientific method you're supposed to
make observations from a hypothesis run
an experiment or collect data and as
actual scientists when we've done all
those things we then write up our
results and share them and when we do
that it is supposed to be fully
reproducible which is to say someone
could take what we wrote go home
recreate the exact same thing and
hopefully get the same result
as science has become much more
computational and just much more complex
this has gotten really hard to do and i
would argue that it's basically
impossible to do without open source
code and r is kind of what we hang our
hat on in terms of achieving
reproducibility in our science
the art ecosystem which includes our
studio github and our markdown enables
us to do better science in less time
there's actually a whole paper about
this and you're welcome to email me if
you'd like to read it
but it it makes the argument both that
our science is better using these tools
because it's transparent and
reproducible
and also it's faster because of all of
the reasons that r can facilitate things
like data cleaning and running complex
models
that make us better at our jobs i
have been working recently on a
particular
way in which we are changing the planet
which is reshuffling species around the
globe
i call this species on the move a lot of
plants animals everything in nature are
moving on average they're going upwards
in elevation deeper into the oceans and
generally towards the poles and almost
certainly it's because they're chasing
cooler climates as where they used to
live has gotten warmer so this is a
video of the historical distribution of
one particular fish near where many of
you live this is the black sea bass you
can see early on it's concentrated kind
of in the mid-atlantic around north
carolina this is these are hot spots of
its density and as the years go on it
moves further north and you can see not
only does it appear in these northern
regions where it didn't used to live but
also has kind of vanished from where it
historically was most abundant so this
is a classic example of a species on the
move and you can imagine that this
causes a lot of challenges for those of
us who are trying to
either preserve
biodiversity or help people have access
to it this is a species that you might
have eaten it's a popular fisheries
target
and
this species on the move brings up a lot
of challenges and questions like
should we allow
fishermen from new jersey to fish black
sea bass even though they never used to
because it was never up there or should
we give all the fishing rights to the
fishermen from north carolina who always
fished it
but would have to literally drive their
boats up to these hot spots that you see
on the map now to still catch it which
is wasteful and inefficient
and this i'm going to talk about this in
the oceans but this challenge is playing
out on land and with all kinds of
species and it's making it really hard
to conserve and manage them
but what we'd really like to know isn't
just where they were in the past and
what the temperature was in the past
which is kind of what i just showed you
it'd be even better to know where
they're going to be next year because
then we could really say okay we can
anticipate these changes in the
environment
and
that gives us much better tools to be
able to manage them
uh with good outcomes for nature and for
people
ecological forecasting in general is a
really hot topic and this is something
that i've gotten increasingly interested
in
but it's also really difficult
explaining the past is much easier than
predicting the future you can come up
with covariates for historical dynamics
and say okay temperature is really
correlated with where things were found
in the past but that's not the same as
saying
i know exactly what will happen next
year those of you in new york are
familiar with this challenge i can tell
you and you'll probably believe me that
climate change has made hurricanes more
frequent and more intense in the
atlantic over the past few decades and
we might all agree that that's true but
i can't tell you
exactly when the next hurricane will
strike and how strong it will be you
probably would love to know that maybe
you're considering buying an apartment
and you really want to know if it's
going to get trashed by the next
hurricane we'll probably never be able
to forecast hurricanes a year out
but it would be helpful to forecast
ecological dynamics with more precision
so that we can make more targeted
management decisions
but ecosystems are really really
complicated
imagine taking a spoonful of dirt from a
tree or a park or a backyard near you
and looking at it under a microscope you
would see bacteria maybe fungi
uh some seeds of plants or some roots
and those would all be interacting
they'd be consuming nutrients some would
grow some would die
i don't think i could even write down a
model to describe those dynamics
terribly well let alone all of the soil
under a tree plus a tree and then
imagine an entire forest with people
interacting with it in animals these
ecosystems are extremely hard to model
but that's what i've been trying to do
so the project i'm going to talk to you
about a little bit today and it's all
implemented in r so i thought it would
be a good way to introduce you to what
uh
people like me have been doing
what i'm trying to do is simulate
near-term shifts in species
distributions that are responding to
temperature and i'm trying this with a
few fish in the atlantic because we have
a lot of data for them
but a lot of data is relative in the
environmental space
in we those of us who work in marine
systems often joke that counting fish is
like counting trees except they're
invisible and they move
the only data that i have are annual
surveys conducted by the federal
government where they go out and go
fishing and then they write down what
was in the net what was there how big it
was how many
that's it
so for a particular species i'm trying
to infer all of the processes that i'm
about to tell you about from
just data that's like okay and these 90
samples there were zero of the fish
you're interested in and then over here
there were two but they were small and
then down here we found eight and they
were pretty big and so on that's all
we've got
what i'm trying to do though is to fit
mechanistic models to those data that i
just described
to estimate process rates that we can
use to simulate the future so
essentially i'm trying to estimate key
rates of how the species biology
responds to temperature
that we can run forward with temperature
projections for the future and ideally
forecast species on the move
uh this as a little bit of the nuts and
bolts of this model
and you're welcome to just take a deep
breath stand up maybe relax for a minute
if this is not your jam
it's a hierarchical bayesian model that
i'm fitting using stan and some great
our packages that have made that
possible
the model has some key features that
allow me to ask these questions it's a
spatial model of course because we want
species to be able to shift
but we approximate the coastline as just
a line with contin contiguous patches
along it each one is a degree high in
latitude
the model is also age structured and
that's because the age of fish which we
can kind of guess from their signs
tells us something about
conditions when they were born so if we
go fishing we just find a ton of fish
that are four years old we might guess
that four years ago conditions were
really good for that fish to migrate in
or to reproduce
we're estimating most of the rates that
we need a few of them come from the
literature and one of them is
temperature dependent only one because
otherwise the model has a very hard time
fitting
like i said the only data that we have
are historical abundance and
distribution so where the fish were how
many of them were
during our training years which is i
think 34
and then we make an annual forecast
every year for the next 10 years
from 2006 to 2015 that we can then
actually test against the real data
we're also testing it against more
conventional ways of understanding
species distributions which are kind of
correlative in nature so if you think
back to that map i showed you of black
sea bass with the
blob moving up the coast
many
tools look at those historical
distributions look at the temperature
where those species were found and then
just project those temperatures forward
in space and say that's where it's going
to be
next year so we're competing this more
mechanistic approach against those
correlative approaches
this is the structure of the bayesian
model in a network diagram which i'll
talk you through briefly and it's in
this kind of um
schematic form so that it's easier to
understand
what makes the model hierarchical are
these different levels and the top level
is
our model for the actual observation
process i would love to say that we are
observing these populations without
error but we definitely aren't some
years the boat didn't run as much
because the government defunded the
program sometimes there wasn't someone
on the boat who's very good at
identifying the fish there are a lot of
sources of observation error
so in this model we say that the data
that we actually observe which are the
number of fish in every patch in this
model every age group and every year
is conditional on the true number which
we never observe and never really know
but we're trying to estimate
plus some parameters all these things
down here parameters related to the
observation process an error term
a term related to the fact that small
fish don't get caught as much
and finally a term related to the fact
that most of the
records that we have are actually zeros
like they didn't find the fish at all so
it's a two-stage model that first says
was the was there a positive encounter
at all and then if yes we model the
population
and we model the population with this
process model that says the true number
of individuals we think this is sort of
a set of equations describing how we're
proposing the world works the true
number of fish in the sea is due to the
number of fish that die that's actually
a term that we get from the literature
the number of fish that migrate in
between the patches which we call
dispersal and the number of new fish
that appear every year from reproductive
reproduction which we call recruitment
here
that's the term in this particular
schematic that we made uh dependent on
temperature although we can move the
temperature dependency around and we
have
so that actually has several parameters
first of all recruitment is just super
stochastic in marine populations we know
that so it has an autocorrelation
parameter to tune the stochasticity
there's also an optimal temperature at
which recruitment is maximized and then
finally
a sensitivity parameter that tells us if
it gets too hot or too cold how quickly
does recruitment drop off
so this is our cartoon of how we're
saying these populations work and we're
trying to fit this model to the data
estimate all of these gray boxes and
then run it forward with projected
temperatures to simulate the future
i would love on this slide to show you
our results but the truth is this model
is not
strictly working perfectly
because as
people who've done this kind of model
you probably know it's really hard to
estimate all the parameters i just
showed you from only the data that we
have in hand
so that's been one challenge the just
the parameter estimation another
challenge has actually been
the data modeling process so i told you
that we in this model structure say that
the observed data are conditional on the
true population size or and state
but
the data that we have are really
strange some the most common thing is
that we have zeros we don't encounter
any fish but for some of these species
you encounter one fish and then less
frequently two and less frequently three
but then also occasionally you encounter
like seven thousand or eight thousand
because they're schooling fish
there's no data distribution in
statistics that from which you can draw
a lot of zeros some ones some twos some
seven thousand some eight thousands
at a frequency that would remotely
reconstruct that data so if anyone has
experience making those types of custom
distributions do let me know
because uh one of the recurring
challenges in
environmental data science and partly
why i wanted to talk about this project
is
our own data limitations and finding the
right statistical approaches to get the
most inference from the data that we
have in hand
but i want to end by coming back to
where we started which is r
and the planet and you
all of the data's described are public
you can go download them they're from
federally conducted surveys
that are freely available on the
internet and it's not just that this is
a link to our open size database of
packages which includes dozens that
access tons and tons of
environmental data sets that could match
any of your personal questions and
interests you might be interested in
plastic pollution in butterflies or bees
maybe you're interested in soil health
or air pollution in communities of um
that have been redlined
all of those data sets are available you
can go use them and go start to explore
the issues that matter to you
but i would encourage you if you do go
down that path which i think is super
exciting of course that's what i'm doing
to be a little bit cautious about using
these data they often have contingencies
like any data set that aren't that
obvious from the start you might notice
in my project that i cut it off at 2015
that's because in 2016
because of a government shutdown this
survey just didn't run so you might look
at the data and think oh my god there
were no fish they all went extinct that
year when in fact it's because of an
issue with the data collection that's
really non-obvious so that's one example
of why partnering with people who have
domain knowledge is really important but
the good news
is that everyone in my field spends way
too much time on twitter and we're
generally very friendly so if any of you
have an interest in exploring
environmental topics i'm sure that you
can connect with an environmental
scientist who would be delighted to
partner with a data scientist like you
who's really excited about exploring the
questions that matter to you personally
thank you so much for your attention and
hopefully we'll chat more later